I'll begin by reminding you when you see
this where you see that this is all the
information you get in the question okay
motion questions because there are so
many different angles for how you can
approach all the dozens of different
motion questions there are right the
information they give you is intended to
be a signal it's meant to say okay
here's kind of the Avenue you want to go
down give me there is going to be one or
two better ways of approaching this than
others okay so you have a look and you
see what we've got is acceleration as a
function of X I shouldn't say I episode
avid user right accelerations a function
of X and then we need to get to velocity
also as a function of it okay our time
will come in later oh i should say they
didn't tell us an initial condition what
is it initially i think really are you
and what's the horsley that's the bosses
too great so track is going to come into
play thank goodness okay who's gonna
have to commit but at the beginning we
are not interested in time okay we're
interested in acceleration velocity and
displacement into a suit on okay right
now where you see acceleration in
particular in terms of velocity that
leads you that to this result instead of
radiant as a function of X screeds
remember this
okay now I'll admit this particular
result it is quite it's quite confusing
to be honest it's one of the main
differences the primary differences
between r2 unit motion and extension of
one motion this is one of the things
okay so how do we wrap our heads around
it let me remind you where it comes from
ok I'll acceleration what's the
definition of acceleration it's a it's
how velocity is changing over time right
so we would write this our velocity is
changing with respect to time ok so
that's fine right but we want to move
away from something with respect to time
and get something in terms of X's right
so we employed chain rule to sort of
rearrange this then do you remember i
can write this like so introduce a deep
x because that's the variable I'm
interested in ok now what can I do to
this what can I do this good you can see
that this this thing here change a
displacement over time that's velocity
right it's all the rewrite this is this
it is solution right and now at this
point this is better I've eliminated
time kotov ok the last thing to
eliminate is this DV I don't what it
with respect to velocity I want to
differentiate with respect to
displacement right so how do i get rid
of it just like in here i introduced
this on DX right to get rid of this DX
i'm going to have to introduce a DB on
the denominator right so I'm going to
differentiate something with respect to
V ok so what do I differentiate with
respect to V little man be here and the
answer is half a square if you
differentiate our v square u x to power
comes down at pops bit cool ok so
there's your DV DX hagen / on the end
tvs will cancel and there's this result
that we're using right now ok so just
thought I'd rehearse that because you
know he led sorry for us and then you're
like
it's not that hard to remember this
because I what does it even mean what's
the point of this by the way
acceleration as a function of
displacement all kinds of forces like
things that accelerate things happen in
terms on where you are like how far you
away from something okay like gravity
actually any of the fundamental forces
where you are in relation to an object
defines what kind of acceleration all
kind of forces that duty okay so that's
why these kinds of things come up so now
let me have that set up how do we use it
okay well let's give this about so this
is plateau this is part 1 i'll start off
by saying look instead of acceleration
or substitute in this is reader looking
phrase okay so the derivative with
respect to X mm-hmm v square is equal to
the sky okay so you can see now my job
is to get to the V on its own get to the
mirror right before i do integrate right
you can see I've got my own your team
and this is all in terms of X I just
tidy this up a little bit because it's
kind of a mess there's only one term on
the denominator so I can just divide
through right the problems okay that's
going to give me let's see negative e to
the negative x by the speed of a of 2x
so far so good and that's really nice
that's easy super easy to different here
okay so there's my derivative so now
integrate you can't go ahead and write
your integral notation but I think this
is such a simple integral that we can
just go straight to the actual it
definitely to go right derivative of
negative e to the negative x will be e
to the negative x sorry I should have
said digital people because if i
differentiate this you'll get back there
okay how about this we almost the same
what difference is the two men i'll need
a half to compensate right saddle right
you can see how you differentiate back
and then of course because I integrated
no boundaries i get my constant okay
great no at this point how do i get that
constant how do I evaluate it I go back
to what I know about the industrial
conditions right in particular I want X
and B so x equals 0 V equals 2 i'm just
going to toss that right in there oh
okay when x equals B equals 2 okay so
I've got a hard times for over there
I've got either not off e to the north
and see okay can we see what we're going
to get here that's one that's a half so
I've got one and a half here or i go
here too i'm going to take away the one
the half looks to me like see okay you
can later that point if you like but
there you go it's not that hard to see
brilliant I've got my constant let's
stick it back in to hear half v square
plus a half ok now we're oh we've made a
lot of progress this is really good
we've gone from we've got rid of our
cell eration we've gotten rid of the
fact that it's a derivative I need to
get to just be on its own ok so first
we'll get rid of that half a deal ok ah
now this does look tricky I'll admit ok
however you have the distinct advantage
of knowing where you need to end up ok
so your honor I'm not be squared I've
got it to V also it's a show question
right you cannot skip any steps so how
am I going to show that this will arrive
here what can you see yeah this is a
square isn't it it's a perfect square
this is where ever it is evidently so
just to make that clear up because I'm
trying to prove right I'm going to
rewrite this parlor reason why it's a
bit difficult to see is this term should
really be at the front shouldn't it it's
actually II to the negative x square
that's what it really is that's why it's
a quadratic okay plus 2x plus 1 cool I
think that's enough to justify but
that's now even X plus 1 all square ok
so far so good right now at this point I
am almost there but i'm not there am i
what's missing what what what's in
between here my final line plus or minus
good ok so you cannot just say well I
need to get there so i'll just take the
positive one right now there is a reason
why we only have to take positive what
is the reason ok so whatever equation we
end up with right it must satisfy these
values or maybe i should put the other
way these values must satisfy whatever i
get here ok so i would say but ok now
which values will i put in again it's
going to be these guys right
I don't even need the particular value
of the varsity I can just say but when x
equals 0 B is positive that's all I need
I just need to pick which case right
it's too which is possible so therefore
be it was this one the positive one only
as required cool